These three choices are correct. At the spot where two lines cross, or
intersect, they have to go through the exact same point, which is why they are
able to touch in the first place. So this point of intersection lies both on
this orange line and on this purple line. They both pass through this location.
Remember, though, that a point on a line gives us x and y values that satisfy
the equation for that line, or in other words, make it true. If a point lies on
both lines, then it must do that for both of those equations. That means that
for any two lines that intersect, there's some pair of x and y values that we
could plug into either equation, and create a true statement for each. This is
the same thing as saying that these values create a solution to both equations.